so so what do we provide so if I just
try to bucket the solutions so I talked
about the problem now now if I come to
the solutions so what are the solutions
informatics based Solutions which are
there in the health care domain so I
have just mentioned six major categories
the first one is prediction
so prediction is actually predicting a
clinical outcome or any outcome from
some
particular predictors or features
the next part is cluster identification
so suppose we have
a cluster of patients now we want to
identify that which cluster is a high
risk Group which is a low risk Group
which is a moderate risk group so these
things also we can do using the AI based
techniques
nowadays there is a very
trend of using fitbits and variables
which help us stream
real-time data blood pressure data and
pulse data so all these things we use
time series modeling for prediction so
for to predict
a clinical outcome predict uh
sudden clinical outcome so these things
we
do using time series Analytics
then there is something called image
analytics so for image we have CT scan
image we have extra images so all these
things we also use informatics for the
purpose
lastly we have also a clinical nodes so
OCR is a very important technique which
we use for informatics
so in case of OCR we actually scan
clinical nodes hand internal nodes
extract the information from there then
apply NLP based techniques to generate
insights may be the most frequently
occurring diseases or the most frequent
complaint and all these things and this
also falls under the domain of physical
Matrix lastly we can combine these major
solutions to build up customized
Solutions
so if so I just gave three particular
more specific use cases so we can
identify cancer subtypes for more
precise therapy because as you know that
cancer is a disease where some persons
are respond to chemotherapy some don't
respond some respond to a particular
drug regimen some don't respond so if we
can detect the cancer subtypes that can
that can help us to
to inject a particular specific drug
regimen which is known as respiration
therapy that is also done using health
informatics
we can detect and classify tumors from
x-ray image and CT scan and lastly a
very interesting thing is mental health
nowadays and by using social network
posts by using NLP we can detect mental
health problems
so this is a overview of the modeling
which we use for health informatics
so the first of all we do have multiple
types of data so
being
being able to explore the data types
having a know-how of how they look
like to find them how to structure them
how to
make them very simple for predictive
purpose so that's a very big challenge
in health informatics so we generally
have electronic health records we have
wireless devices we have medical devices
clinical notes there are multiple types
of data sources now all these data
sources have to be converted into a
machine readable format for modeling
purpose so this is a very important area
of healthcare data and this requires
lots of expertise and
insight to do that so the first step is
data preparation from this multiple data
sources
after data preparation we can bucket
them into specific
subgroups demographic features comorbit
conditions surveys vitals like that and
those things we can input to our
training sets for our for the model
training and we can use them to predict
a particular clinical outcome and we
will also test it into a different and
independent set and we can use it in
that fashion now as new data comes in
the training would become more and more
precise and the model would get updated
accordingly so this is a very general
overview of modeling so I just wanted to
mention it so we will be using multiple
types of modeling we will be learning
multiple modeling techniques in the
course
more specific and of course we will also
be doing some very Hands-On hands-on
experience from our example data set and
predicting the condition from
ourselves